la séance est ouverte de contreduit
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je ne vois pas le procès-verbal est donc
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en
direction Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun sera attentif au respect à la
fois du temps de parole et des uns et
des autres et je donne immédiatement la
parole au président Patrick canaire pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci président madame la Première
ministre en préambule à ma question je
rappelle un principe intangible la
violence ne peut en aucun cas être une
réponse à mécontentement social ou
politique aussi au nom de mon groupe je
condamne l'agression dont a été victime
Jean-Baptiste trogneux et lui apporte
notre total soutien
je manifeste le même soutien à Yannick
Morez mère de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins qui
a subi intimidation harcèlement et
agression autant d'actes un qualifiables
envers un élu de la République qui ne
faisait qu'exercer son mandat il mérite
également mes chers collègues le respect
le soutien indéfectible du Sénat
oui mes chers collègues un vent mauvais
souffle sur notre pays un maire de
France a dû céder devant la menace la
violence la haine l'a emporté sur la
bienveillance la force l'a emporté sur
le droit la multiplication des pressions
des agressions envers les élus et
quantifiables et documentés les élus
locaux et plus particulièrement les mers
sont les fondations de la République
quand une de ces fondations s'écroule
comme avec la démission donnée de Morez
c'est tous les défis qui est fragilisé
l'audition émouvante de ce dernier ce
matin par la commission du des lois du
Sénat c'est transformé en réquisitoire
contre les services de l'État tente ont
été révélés de graves défaillance c'est
un échec madame la Première ministre
pour ne pas dire un désastre dont il
faut tirer toutes les conséquences dès
aujourd'hui
Saint-Brévin c'est aussi le signe d'une
résurgence des violences de l'extrême
droite depuis plusieurs semaines ces
actes de terrorisme intellectuel et
physique se sont multipliées pour
empêcher les mers qui le veulent de
prendre part l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile madame ma première ministre on
ne peut mettre sur un pied d'égalité
l'extrême droite et d'autres formes de
contestation l'extrême droite que ce
soit au sein de nos institutions ou dans
le cadre d'action clandestine et
l'ennemi mortel de notre démocratie
l'État ne peut rester larmes aux pieds
face à ces menaces allez-vous engager ce
combat pour défendre les élus de la
République
on vous répond de la parole de madame la
Première ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick
depuis des semaines Yannick Morez le
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a été
victime d'une campagne insupportable de
harcèlement en lien avec un projet
d'implantation d'un centre d'accueil
pour demandeur d'asile dans sa commune
et fin mars son domicile a été incendié
alors oui ces actes sont inadmissibles
derrière chaque élu agressé c'est la
République qui est visée
avec chacun de vous et en évitant toutes
polémique monsieur le Président kaner je
partage le choc et l'indignation face à
cette situation comme face à chaque acte
de violence contre les élus en
présentant sa démission Yannick Morel
après une décision difficile en son âme
est conscience nous ne pouvons que
regretter qu'il était conduit à faire ce
choix et naturellement nous le
respectons je le recevrai tout à l'heure
avec l'Association des maires de
Loire-Atlantique et l'Association des
maires de France mon objectif est de
l'écouter et de lui exprimer le soutien
de mon gouvernement les mers sont en
première ligne sur le terrain ils sont
les premiers témoins de la montée de la
défiance dans notre société nous devons
les protéger nous devons protéger tous
les élus et pour y parvenir le
gouvernement s'engage le ministre de
l'Intérieur les préfets et les forces
les forces de l'ordre sont mobilisées le
droit pénal a été renforcé pour
permettre aux associations d'élus et aux
collectivités de se constituer partie
civile à plusieurs reprises le ministre
de la Justice a demandé au procureur des
réponses fermes rapides visibles contre
les atteintes aux élus et nous sommes
prêts à travailler avec vous comme avec
l'Assemblée nationale pour renforcer les
sanctions pénales contre les violences
envers les aigus et nous voulons aller
plus loin depuis des mois nous préparons
des mesures nouvelles que la Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
Dominique Faure présentera tout à
l'heure il s'agit de renforcer le lien
entre les mers et la justice de mieux
prévenir les violences et d'accompagner
encore davantage les élus c'est un sujet
auquel je tiens particulièrement et que
j'avais eu l'occasion d'évoquer avec
l'ensemble des associations d'élus le 12
avril dernier
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il
n'y a pas de démocratie sans respect des
élus pas de démocratie sont sécurité
pour les élus avec vous tous avec le
gouvernement nous continuerons à agir je
vous remercie
quelques secondes
merci président madame la Premier
ministre les élus de la République
demande pas de compassion il demande de
l'action et qu'il puisse agir eux-mêmes
et quand madame Dominique Faure évoque
la création d'un centre d'analyse pour
savoir ce qui se passe dans le pays
permettez-moi de vous dire que nous le
savons depuis bien longtemps que tout
est quantifié et quantifiable et que
nous demandons simplement que la
réflexion qui est menée notamment au
Sénat puisse être appliquée pour
protéger les élus de la République
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen je vais la parole merci
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur
Madame la Ministre avec mes collègues
Jean-François Husson et Véronique del
Fabro je vous interpelle sur les faits
qui se sont déroulés samedi à Villerupt
en plein centre ville à deux pas d'un
parc pour enfants une fusillade a eu
lieu sur fond de trafic de drogue le
bilan humain et la violence des faits
ont profondément choqué et bouleverser
les habitants cinq blessés trois dans un
état grave tout s'était âgé entre 17 et
30 ans mes pensées vont bien sûr aux
victimes à leur famille à toutes les
villes ruptiens et toutes les villes
russiennes à qui nous devons apporter
des réponses tout le monde est choqué
mais personne ne semblait surpris or ce
point de vie l'avait pignon sur rue
depuis des mois les tarifs des
stupéfiants sont encore inscrits sur les
murs à côté d'une fresque d'enfants ce
drame mais effectivement lumière le
débat récurrent du sous-effectif
chronique de la circonscription de
police longuyville rue il manque à ce
jour 15 policiers au moins vendredi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé
l'ouverture de 11 postes si cette
nouvelle part d'une bonne intention il y
a peu de chance que ces postes soient
pourvus par défaut d'attractivité du
territoire madame la ministre qui s'est
passé est grave suite aux échanges que
nous avons eu ces derniers jours avec le
cabinet je salue l'arrivée d'un escadron
de gendarme mobile dès cet après-midi à
Villerupt pour autant à moyen terme et
afin de remonter les effectifs
comptez-vous nous affecter des policiers
en sortie d'école
enfin un dernier regret la ville
ruptiale que je suis n'a jusqu'ici pas
réussi à convaincre les aigus locaux de
la nécessité de se saisir de tous les
outils contra local de santé police
municipale
vidéoprotection je crois que c'est tous
ensemble pas en opposant les uns aux
autres c'est tous ensemble en laissant
tomber les idéologies que nous ferons
reculer la délinquance la mise en place
d'une réunion de concertation locale en
urgence s'impose il y va de la sécurité
et de la tranquillité des habitants je
compte sur le ministre car il est encore
temps d'enrayer cette spirale infernale
j'en suis convaincu
vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales
madame Faure merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Guillotin oui ce qui s'est
passé est très grave vous l'avez rappelé
samedi dernier dans la soirée les
effectifs de police intervenaient pour
plusieurs coups de feu tirés dans le
centre-ville de ville-europe
villeuruptes en Meurthe et Moselle sur
place les policiers découvrent cinq
blessés par balle dont trois sont en
urgence absolue d'après les premiers
éléments cette tentative d'homicide
serait en lien avec le trafic de
stupéfiant dans le cadre d'une
recrudescence de la violence entre bande
rivale pour le contrôle de ce trafic
quelques heures après l'effet l'auteur
présumé de la fusillade a été interpellé
par la police judiciaire de Metz
assistée par la BRI je tiens ici à
remercier tous les policiers pour leur
mobilisation et leur action rapide et
efficace sur instruction de Gérald
Darmanin escadron de gendarmerie mobile
soit 70 gendarmes vous l'avez dit a été
envoyé sur place des hier ils seront en
place au moins jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine pour la circonscription de
police dans dépend il Rupt le ministre
de l'Intérieur annonce ouverture vous
l'avez dit aussi de poste par ailleurs
44 nouveaux postes seront ouverts sur
l'ensemble du département meurt et
Moselle nous constatons que le trafic de
drogue touche aujourd'hui les villes de
taille moyenne comme la vôtre c'est
pourquoi nous devons lutter contre ce
trafic à tous les niveaux je pense à
l'excellent travail réalisé par les
policiers des Yvelines qui ont effectué
une saisie record de deux tonnes 5 de
cannabis pour une valeur marchande de 20
millions d'euros il y a seulement
quelques jours je sais que tous les élus
concernés sont particulièrement
mobilisés sur le sujet et
particulièrement vous les sénateurs
hussons chacun d'elfabro et vous-même
madame la sénatrice pour cette raison et
vous l'avez indiqué le préfet va réunir
l'ensemble des élus concernés dans les
plus belles délais cette réunion est
d'ores et déjà programmée je vous
remercie
quelques secondes madame Guillotin
oui quelques secondes pour dire
qu'effectivement quand on voit un tel
drame et qu'on entend dans la rue dire
que ça n'étonne en fait quasiment
personne je crois qu'il y a des vrais
leçons à prendre l'État doit assumer ses
responsabilités l'État ne doit pas
défaillir mais ses mains dans la main
état et les locaux que nous devons
travailler et faire reculer cette
délinquance merci la parole est à notre
collègue Renan Dantec pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre yannick morrez a démissionné et
il ne reviendra pas sur sa décision le
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins est ainsi
devenu depuis quelques jours le symbole
des difficultés des élus locaux à
exercer leur mandat non plus seulement à
porter d'engueulade mais bien de
calomnie d'agressions aussi et dans ce
cas d'un attentat criminel qui aurait pu
le tuer sa femme et lui il y a une
mauvaise n'a pas démissionné par peur ou
par lassitude il a démissionné parce que
l'État ne l'a pas protégé Yanni Morel
depuis l'incendie de sa maison le 22
mars était devenu le symbole du courage
de l'élu républicain celui qui assume
sans faiblir la tâche que lui a confié
l'État en l'occurrence le déménagement
d'un centre d'accueil pour demandeur
d'asile un cada déjà installé sans
problème dans la commune depuis 2016 il
est en tribune et c'est d'abord à ce
titre que nous lui rendons hommage il
tenait bon face à la haine de l'extrême
droite et des sbires Éric Zemmour
monsieur le ministre qu'il n'y ait pas
de faux débat nous condamnons tous ici
toutes les violences politiques et je
veux associer à l'expression de notre
dégoût face à ce cas subi Yanni Morel
c'est ignoble passage à tabac avant-hier
du neveu de Madame Brigitte Macron c'est
aussi un acte un qualifiable et la
justice doit être ferme dans un cas
comme dans l'autre mais je vous demande
mais je vous demande précisément
monsieur le ministre de répondre aux
interrogations de Yannick Morel nous lui
devons cette clarté première question
pourquoi Yannick Morel n'a-t-il pas fait
l'objet d'une protection rapprochée de
l'État depuis le mois de mars deuxième
question pourquoi avoir autorisé la
manifestation anticada du 29 avril un
mois après l'incendie véritable désaveu
du maire qui avait pourtant demandé son
interdiction le 14 mai le 14 avril
après Kalak après Saint-Brevin et avant
d'autres drames allez-vous enfin
interdire ce type de manifestation qui
sont d'évidence appel à la haine de la
part de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dans tech
d'abord vous me permettrez en saluant
Yannick Maurice de me réjouir de l'image
que vient de donner le Sénat puisque
aucun membre n'est resté assis au moment
de l'hommage qui lui a été rendu alors
que nous avons assisté hier
alors que nous avons assisté hier à
l'Assemblée nationale à une scène ou une
partie de l'hémicycle ne s'est pas levée
et je pense que ça témoigne précisément
et je pense que sa témoigne précisément
de la volonté qu'il y a
de la
j'aimerais
prétendre défendre la liberté
d'expression en empêchant quelqu'un de
s'exprimer et toujours quelque chose qui
m'a semblé bizarre je commence ce propos
en saluant le fait que tous les élus sur
tous les bancs ici se lèvent alors
qu'hier le rassemblement national a
refusé de se joindre à l'hommage et vous
prétextez que compte tenu de la
formulation de ma phrase ça engendrerait
la moindre gêne
c'est un début de récupération que de
laisser penser qu'il y aurait une façon
qui serait à géométrie variable de
décrire les choses et je veux saluer les
propos de ronanantec qui sont la moindre
hésitation et avec le sens républicain
conduit connaît on a profité aussi pour
rappeler les faits inacceptable subis
par le petit neveu du président de la
République dans un confinement de
violence qui de cette manière-là se
retrouve mesdames et messieurs vous avez
ce matin reçu Yannick Maurice dans le
cadre d'une mission plus large portée
par le sédiateur d'Arnaud par l'avenir
de la commune nous allons avoir trois
quatre cinq questions qui seront autant
d'occasions de vous répondre dans les
minutes qui viennent
et je me réjouis que le Sénat au travers
de cette exemple d'un acte de courage
d'intimidation et d'un niveau de
violence qui a été franchi et qui a
atteint des paliers inacceptables essaye
de faire la lumière ce que je souhaite
dans le même temps y compris contenu des
retours que nous avons c'est que vous en
profitiez peut-être pour demander aux
forces de l'ordre à ceux qui travaillent
au sein de Loire-Atlantique qu'elle a
été leur version de leur côté les
retours qu'ils ont eu dans les éléments
qui nous sont donnés il y a eu des
patrouilles de police plusieurs nuits
dans la foulée immédiate du 22 mars je
vous dis ce que je sais il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites auprès
d'yannique Mores pour faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent bénéficier d'un
accompagnement et des tentatives de
prise de contact de la part de la
préfecture ou de la sous-préfecture
j'entends y compris dans la lecture de
ce qui a été l'audition ce matin qui a
manifestement sur l'absence de réunion
publique sur des manifestations qui se
sont tenues des zones d'ombre qui
convient d'éclaircir ce que je pense
c'est qu'une commission aussi importante
que celle là sur un sujet aussi sensible
nécessite sans doute que vous y passiez
encore un peu plus de temps que ce que
vous aviez pu imaginer
quelques secondes monsieur Dantec il
vous reste quelques secondes si vous le
souhaitez oui juste monsieur le ministre
je crois qu'il n'y aurait pas de honte à
reconnaître que sur cette affaire l'État
n'a pas été à l'auteur ça faciliterait
les choses
l'état notre corps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoires
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en novembre 2022 le Sénat en
initiative de notre collègue Nathalie
Delattre a voté une loi promulguée en
janvier dernier permettant aux
associations d'élus de se constituer
partie civile pour se tenir les élus ou
leurs proches victimes d'agression ce
texte va aujourd'hui la possibilité à
Yannick Morez mère de Saint-Brévin
d'être défendu par l'Association des
maires de France j'ai invité Yannick
Morez aux tribune et je suis très
heureux de l'hommage que vous venez de
lui rendre
[Applaudissements]
en avril j'ai animé en sa présence une
réunion avec plus de 50 élus de
loire-atlantiques sur ce sujet tous ont
témoignés d'incivilité et d'agression
dont ils font l'objet ils ressortait un
profond mal-être et de la colère car les
élus portent plainte mais bien souvent
rien ne change trop de plaintes sont
classées sans suite et les auteurs
recommencent de plus belle à titre
d'exemple le maire de Saint-Père-en-Retz
commune voisine de Saint-Brevin est
agressée par le même individu depuis
plus de trois ans hier Jean-Baptiste
trogneux a été victime d'une agression
odieuse uniquement parce qu'il est le
petit neveu du président de la
République
ces agressions prennent aujourd'hui des
formes multiples certains se cachent
derrière l'anonymat des réseaux sociaux
pour harceler menacer insulter toute
autorité publique et leur famille
d'autres se rendent coupables de
violences physiques
l'ensemble est favorisé par des discours
haineux de certains responsables
politiques on ne peut pas appeler à la
violence et sans laver les mains il faut
que la justice passe avec fermeté il
s'agit avant tout de dissuader en amont
en sanctionnant des coupables par des
mesures plus
coercitives monsieur le ministre comment
assurer à nos élus à leur famille que la
nation et l'État se tiennent à leur côté
et que ces actes ne restent pas impunis
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Christophe Béchu monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
je n'aurai aucune difficulté quand nous
irons au terme de l'ensemble de la
lumière qui est nécessaire sur ce qui
s'est fait à Saint-Brévin à partager
avec vous et le constat et la
reconnaissance des dysfonctionnements
s'il y en a eu et je veux dire à Yannick
morrèze on le regarde que son exemple a
beaucoup d'égard il nous oblige
parce qu'il suppose de mesurer qu'il y a
à la fois les actes pour lesquels des
élus peuvent parce que ça correspond
leur décision et d'autres dans lequel il
s'agit d'aller partager une
responsabilité nationale il y a un an
j'étais maire
comme beaucoup ici les intimidations les
invectives les insultes les trucs dans
les réseaux sociaux les commentaires
haineux les affiches les tract anonymes
je connais beaucoup d'entre nous
connaissent l'année dernière c'est
2265 atteintes à des élus
32% de plus qu'en 2021
en face
compte tenu à la fois du durcissement
des textes
945 sanctions pénales quand on a été
capable de retrouver les auteurs l'enjeu
c'est de franchir de nouveaux paliers
monsieur le sénateur guerriot d'abord
pas seulement analyser comme le dit le
président Kanner mais faire un centre de
coordination de la lutte contre les élus
comment la justice comment la
gendarmerie et la police sont en
capacité les partager des informations
par rapport aux menaces qui visent les
élus et comment on est capable d'y
répondre y compris en systématisant le
suivi de la protection et de
l'accompagnement des élus deuxième chose
nous avons vous avez parlementaire à une
très large majorité considérez que le
port de l'uniforme
devait être une circonstance aggravante
parce que quand on s'en prend un pompier
un gendarme ou un policier derrière
l'uniforme c'est aux valeurs de la
République qu'on s'attaque est-ce que
l'écharpe tricolore n'est pas à bien des
égards une forme d'uniforme républicain
qui mériterait la même reconnaissance
des circonstances aggravantes est-ce que
nous ne pourrions pas là aussi
considérer que ce n'est pas seulement la
personne du maire qui est visée mais sa
fonction et à travers elle ceux qui lui
ont été donnés mandat c'est-à-dire la
République et la démocratie
monsieur guerriot
merci monsieur le ministre dans le cadre
de Yannick Morel c'est l'accumulation de
fait avant même qui est une réaction qui
pose problème il aurait fallu très
rapidement réagir c'est avant tout la
démocratie qu'il s'agit de protéger et
pour cela et bien il faut absolument que
nos coupables les coupables des faits et
bien et peur de notre justice
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Catherine belriti pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
garde des sceaux la démission de Yannick
Morez maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins le
9 mai dernier a suscité indignation
générale et un tolemédiatique sans
précédent intimidé depuis des mois
abandonné par un appareil étatique resté
sourd à ces avertissements celui-ci a
finalement rendu son écharpe suite à
l'instant du criminel de son logement
familial dans la nuit du 22 mars dernier
ce drame républicain est malheureusement
loin d'être isolé en effet depuis le
décès tragique du maire de signe en 2019
les agressions envers les élus de la
République se sont multipliés vous le
disiez tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre 2265 plaintes et signalement en
2022 soit une hausse de 32% en un an
pire encore selon le président de la MF
David Linard le seuil pathétique des
millemets démissionnaires depuis les
municipales de 2020 a été franchie nous
en sommes aujourd'hui à 1293 démissions
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion d'alerter le
gouvernement sur la recrudescence des
agressions envers les élus le 13 avril
dernier madame la ministre fort ma belle
alors annoncé la création prochaine d'un
centre d'analyse et de lutte contre les
atteintes aux élus mais nous savons tous
ceux qui se passe sur le terrain un mois
plus tard aucune réponse pénale adaptée
ne semble à l'ordre du jour et une
certaine impunité règne pour les auteurs
de ses agressions à l'initiative du
Sénat la loi du 24 janvier 2023 permet
aux associations d'élus de se constituer
partie civile pour soutenir au pénal un
élu victime d'agression cependant les
sanctions ne sont pas à la hauteur
monsieur le ministre combien de
démission supplémentaires faudra-t-il
pour intensifier la répression envers
les auteurs de ses attaques et préserver
ainsi le pacte républicain
bon vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on aime la
sénatrice belle retti je voudrais tout
d'abord évidemment m'associer à vos mots
pour dire à quel point ces violences
sont inacceptables je veux redire à
Monsieur le Maire tout mon soutien toute
notre solidarité au nom de la première
ministre au nom de Christophe Vichy au
nom de Gérald Darmanin au nom de tout le
gouvernement
dans notre République c'est inacceptable
nous devons briser la spirale de la
violence faite aux élus on ne laissera
rien passer cette violence et d'autant
plus inacceptable que j'étais mère
moi-même jusqu'au 7 juillet dernier et
qu'on sait à quel point les mers et que
vous représentez tous ici en fait sont
les garant de la sécurité sur leur
commune de la protection de
l'environnement de l'action sociale sur
leur commune ils sont dans l'intérêt
général on sait à quel point ils sont
dans le don de soi
cependant je ne peux pas ne pas rappeler
très brièvement à quel point nous sommes
dans l'action vous l'avez dit la
sénatrice de l'être a permis par sa PPL
le fait que les associations d'élus
puisse se porter partie civiles oui
c'est un élément oui la loi qui a été
portée en 2019 par notre collègue
Sébastien Lecornu engagement et
proximité vise à renforcer comme l'a dit
madame la Première ministre la
protection des élus oui des circulaires
pas moins de 3 qui ont été envoyés au
parquet demandant une réponse pénale
ferme et rapide cependant est-ce que
pour autant nous en restons là est-ce
que pour autant nous voulons amplifier
ce qui est fait ce que nous voulons
aller plus loin la réponse est oui et là
je m'adresse à vous monsieur sénateurs
qui n'avait cité que ce centre de lutte
que ce centre d'analyse que j'ai cité
effectivement dans un de mes propos mais
ce n'est pas que cela nous sommes aussi
là pour d'abord et avant tout protéger
les élus donc nous allons amplifier ce
que nous faisons et j'aurai le plaisir
de l'annoncer ce soir après avoir
rencontré Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brévin au côté de Madame la
première ministre parce que l'action
vous l'avez tous surveillé au corps nous
aussi au gouvernement nous l'avons
chevillé au corps l'action et donc ce
soir je dévoile le risque que nous
allons faire à court terme là maintenant
pour protéger nos élus mais aussi je
vous expliquerai pourquoi comprendre est
important pourquoi ce centre de lutte
est important pourquoi le choc civique
est important et nous apporterons aussi
madame la sénatrice une réponse
judiciaire je vous remercie
madame la ministre ce qui arrive à
monsieur Morin n'est pas isolé je crois
que tout ce qui arrive renvoie à
l'incapacité chronique de réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État l'urgence est là
sans mesurerpressives appropriée le
mandat municipal est menacé et sans les
maires c'est la République elle-même qui
menace ruine
merci
la parole de ta notre collègue Françoise
Gatel pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci
monsieur le Président les difficultés
les démissions s'enchaînent et ses
graines comme les questions aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas que ce
serait ardu très difficile voire risquer
beaucoup de citoyens ce sont engagés
juste pour servir homme et femme de
devoirs plutôt que de pouvoir les mères
sont trop souvent contraints empêcher
démunies submergé de normes et
d'injonctions mais il reste responsable
de tout les voici aujourd'hui avec leur
famille confrontés au délitement et à la
violence de la société qui les prend
pour cible de la mort du maire de signe
en 2019 à la démission 6 symbolique de
Monsieur le Maire de Saint-Brévin que je
salue avec beaucoup de respect des
missions et difficultés s'enchaînent
certes des dispositions ont été votées
mises en œuvre il faut l'admettre car
nous connaissons les remèdes éduqués
protéger sanctionner et surtout prévenir
et empêcher ceci suppose que le couple
mère préfet que nous avons tant célébré
pendant la crise du covid soit fort et
puissant partout dans tous les
territoires et auprès de tous les élus à
force Yori quand les tâches amères
d'exécuter une mission en son nom madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre je sais
pas qui me répondra écoute émotion nous
le faisons tout je sais que ça n'est pas
simplement votre attitude mais cela ne
suffit pas quand ta mère doit détourner
le regard devant ses agresseurs il nous
l'a dit ce matin quand ta mère est
condamné à quitté la commune pour
laquelle il s'est engagé et à changer de
vie l'heure est vraiment la
détermination et à l'action la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin la démission
des mers nous oblige madame la ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement avant que vous les
précisiez à la télévision on serait ravi
de les avoir ici au Parlement
la parole est à la ministre délégué dans
charge des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs sénatrice Gatel
donc pour redire et il redire à Monsieur
le Maire il y a tous les maires qui font
l'objet de violence faite aux élus c'est
dernière semaine mais j'ai envie de vous
dire tout à fait en introduction que le
diagnostic nous le partageons que c'est
par l'écoute c'est par la proximité
c'est par le respect les uns des autres
c'est par la solidarité mais aussi c'est
par l'action je vous le redis monsieur
le sénateur que l'on va pouvoir endiguer
cette violence faite aux élus alors vous
parlez de la du couple préfet mère on le
connaît tous ici il est efficace il est
à l'action alors bien sûr nous allons
écouter Monsieur le Maire et nous allons
écouter je l'écouterai aux côtés de
madame la Première ministre les raisons
qui lui font percevoir que effectivement
les services de l'État n'ont pas été à
la hauteur de vos attentes et on va vous
écouter et ça dans l'esprit de ce qu'a
dit Christophe Béchu tout à l'heure de
toujours s'améliorer oui on va
s'améliorer de ce que vous allez nous
dire Monsieur le Maire et de votre
perception de cette inaction perçue par
vous moi je veux pas rappeler ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on a le
sentiment d'avoir agi cependant on est
vraiment à l'écoute et avec une envie
chevillée au corps d'avancer alors vous
me demandez de dévoiler quelques actions
seulement il s'agit ici de vous le dire
en deux minutes donc c'est un peu court
me semble-t-il mais je voudrais juste
citer un point un point
ça s'appelle l'alarme élu c'est 3000
référents dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police nationale qui seront dès le début
de la semaine prochaine investis de une
extrême proximité ce sera des référents
violents aux élus ça a été décidé par le
début de la semaine par Gérald Darmanin
et c'est ce qui va faire juste si vous
voulez bien m'écouter une seconde c'est
super important j'ai plus que 10
secondes alarme élu ça veut dire qu'il
faut que vous invitiez les maires à
donner leur numéro de téléphone au
préfet au gendarmes ou à la police pour
que quand ils appelleront écoutez moi
pour que
pour que quand ils appelleront ils
puissent bénéficier d'un traitement
spécifique messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs je vous en dirai plus un peu
plus tard merci à vous
la parole est à notre collègue Cécile Cu
Karman pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les élus
leur famille sont de plus en plus
confrontés à des actes de violence
d'agressions d'intimidation parce qu'ils
agissent pour l'intérêt de leur
population de leur collectivité et de
leur territoire je veux au nom de mon
groupe leur apporter tout mon soutien et
redire qu'aucune violence n'est
acceptable la violence n'est pas dans
l'ADN de notre sensibilité politique
nous serons toujours dans le camp de
ceux qui la condamnent la démission de
notre collègue mère de
Saint-Brévin-les-Pins n'est pas un coup
de tonnerre dans un ciel serein elle
fait suite aux intimidations et menaces
répétées de l'extrême droite depuis
plusieurs semaines elle s'ajoute au plus
de 4000 démissions des lieux municipaux
depuis 2020 dont plus de 1200 m
la non-action ainsi que la banalisation
de cette violence permettent aux auteurs
d'agir sans limite cela met en danger
les élus leur famille mais aussi notre
démocratie notre République nous devons
donc redonner du sens à l'engagement le
sacralisé nous avons tous notre rôle à
jouer en responsabilité les communes
qu'elles soient rurales urbaines ou
d'outre-mer demeure le premier lieu de
vie et de solidarité cellules de base de
la République elles doivent retrouver
toutes leurs places dans l'organisation
démocratique de notre pays cette une
urgence démocratique c'est une urgence
pour la République Monsieur le Ministre
comment entendez-vous redonner du sens à
l'engagement de ces milliers d'élus
locaux qui au quotidien agissent pour
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt de
chacune et de chacun comment
entendez-vous éviter de
telles dysfonctionnement à l'avenir
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice que Karman
d'abord
vous l'avez dit au-delà de Saint-Brévin
c'est plus largement le sens de
l'engagement municipal le sens de
l'engagement de mère que nous devons
évoquer et mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde
la démission du maire de Saint-Brévin a
été poussé par des manifestants
d'extrême droite et provoquées par un
acte scandaleux visant sa famille et son
intégrité physique mais les 1293 des
missions depuis trois ans elles n'ont
pas toutes la même cause certaines sont
liées à des violences de tous origines
parfois sans arrière-pensée politique
lié à la bêtise à des conflits voisinage
et dans d'autres cas à des affaires
internes aux équipes à des difficultés
par rapport au poids des normes à la
multiplicité des réunions à des
difficultés dans une intercommunalité
entre mère en nombre de démission amis
mandat nous en sommes au même nombre en
ce qui concerne les mers
1400 sur les trois premières années du
mandat 2014 2020
1293 quand on s'arrête au mois de mars
sur les trois premières années avec la
parenthèse covid qui bouleverse sans
doute une partie de l'analyse puisque
certains mandats ont commencé avec du
retard je me réjouis de l'initiative
transpartizane de l'avenir de la commune
et je serai heureux d'être auditionné
comme c'est prévu pour vous préciser ce
à quoi nous pensons le sujet du statut
de l'élu
la question du nombre de réunions et
même je vais vous dire puisque c'est un
sujet sur lequel vous travaillez
le statut du secrétaire de mairie du
collaborateur qui permet de soulager de
manière concrète le maire voilà une
oeuvre utile pour faire en sorte
d'avancer et de regarder comment on peut
de manière intelligente faire en sorte
de limiter une part de la charge mentale
qui accompagne la fonction municipale et
puis collectivement tel que vous venez
de le faire refusez toutes les violences
refuser toutes les excuses à ceux qui
décident d'utiliser autre chose que la
démocratie pour remettre en cause des
démissions c'est le bon moyen parce que
ça commence avec le coup d'école qui se
justifie avec le courrier anonyme parce
que le terrain est pas constructible et
ça se poursuit après par un changement
de nature dans les actes et c'est au
premier signe que nous devons faire
rempart collectivement pour protéger les
élus je sais à quel point le Sénat dans
sa plus la réalité est aux côtés des
élus et se tient précisément pour faire
en sorte de les préserver madame cut
Karman vous avez quelques secondes
la parole est à notre collègue Dominique
Théophile pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
madame la ministre chers collègues je
salue bien sûr la présence du maire
Yannick et m'associe avec le groupe RDPI
à l'hommage qui vient d'être rendu nous
devons condamner toutes les formes de
violence madame la ministre dimanche en
Guadeloupe une mère de famille est morte
au volant de sa voiture elle a reçu une
balle dans la tête
mercredi ce sont deux jeunes hommes de
18 et 22 ans qui ont trouvé la mort au
Lamentin et aux Abymes en Guadeloupe eux
aussi par arme à feu ces drames ce sont
les derniers en date d'une liste qui ne
cesse de s'allonger depuis le début de
l'année une quarantaine de personnes ont
ainsi été blessées ou tués par balle
dans notre archipel sans qu'il ne soit
permis d'espérer un retour au calme
cette violence nous ne la découvrons pas
depuis quelques années elle explose en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique elle
s'accompagne d'un phénomène de gang et
se nourrit du trafic d'armes à feu qui
déséquilibre la Caraïbe et qui
ensanglanta
le pouvoir public compris la mesure de
ce phénomène et il me faut saluer le
travail exceptionnel des forces de
l'ordre et des fonctionnaires de justice
il y a quelques mois c'est une vaste
opération menée sous l'égide d'interpols
qui a ainsi permis la saisie d'armes et
de munitions cette réponse pourtant
n'est pas suffisante elle le sera quand
ils seront ces drames qui en deuil
chaque semaine des familles madame la
ministre quelle réponse supplémentaire
entendez-vous apporter pour enrayer ce
cycle de violence comment mieux lutter
contre un trafic d'armes qui dépasse de
loin nos frontières les collectivités
locales la société civile et les
familles sont engagées dans ce combat au
quotidien
elles attendent de l'État une réponse
forte et déterminée nous ne pouvons pas
tenir les armes circulent comme un achat
dans un commerce
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre
délégué en charge des collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur
le mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Théophile vous avez
raison la Guadeloupe et la Martinique
connaissent depuis quelques années une
hausse des violences avec armes et des
homicides l'utilisa Sion d'armes à feu
est en constante augmentation étant à se
banaliser avec une utilisation régulière
par des primo délinquants dans le but de
se protéger en Guadeloupe 230 armes ont
ainsi été saisies dans ce cadre en 2022
ce qui démontre la banalisation du
transport et du port d'armes sur le
territoire alors des actions de
prévention d'abord campagne de
communication et diffusion de messages
télévisuels sur les chaînes locales et
sur les réseaux sociaux financés par le
fond le FIPD mais vous le savez réunion
régulière de concertation avec la
société civile afin de développer de
plus en plus de bonnes pratiques mais
aussi la multiplication des opérations
de contrôle menées à l'appui d'arrêter
préfectoraux spécifiques interdisant la
vente la détention et le transport
d'armes de catégorie C3 et d sur le
territoire de ces deux départements
ensuite le développement le
développement des moyens d'enquête
judiciaires notamment d'enquêteurs
spécialisés
spécialisée cyber chargée d'enquêter sur
la vente et l'achat d'armes par Internet
en 2022 un enquêteur nouvelle
technologie de la gendarmerie ainsi
contribué à l'identification de
plusieurs trafics et aux démantèlement
de l'atelier de transformation de
pistolet d'alarme en armes létale située
sur la commune du Robert
la coopération avec les États voisins
relance des échanges avec Sainte-Lucie
dans le cadre de la commission mixte
renforcement de la coopération avec la
maréchaussée de Saint-Martin tout ça
vous le savez mais il faut poursuivre
renforcer soyez convaincus monsieur le
sénateur de l'engagement total du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour et de
l'outre-mer pour continuer la lutte
contre les trafics à Marseille pas
seulement en Guadeloupe et à la
Martinique merci
la parole est notre collègue Arnaud
Bazin pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et des finances
on l'avait bien compris elle était 2021
c'était juré le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est fini pour la loi de finance 2023
le mantra avait un peu changé c'était
chaque euro compte et en même temps
depuis quelques semaines le président de
la République et le gouvernement
rivalise d'annonce de dépenses nouvelles
supplémentaires par centaines de
millions voir par milliards d'euros 2
milliards d'euros pour le plan vélo 2
milliards d'euros de baisse pour l'impôt
des classes moyennes un milliard d'euros
pour les lycées professionnels cela peut
représenter 18 milliards d'euros en
cumulé d'ici la fin du quinquennat dans
le même temps les intérêts de la dette
cette année vont augmenter de 12
milliards d'euros bientôt le service de
la dette sera le premier budget de
l'État et l'impôt sur le revenu des
Français ni suffira même plus
dans le même temps les prévisions
économiques du gouvernement nous les
avions jugés optimistes en examinant la
loi de finances 1% de croissance ce
n'est pas ce que nous observerons le FMI
avait dit 06 %, c'est sensiblement ce
qui se confirme dans les premiers
chiffres que nous avons alors dans ce
contexte
incertain pour ne pas dire inquiétant
des finances publiques quand cette
baisse d'impôts en faveur des classes
moyennes pourra-t-elle avoir lieu
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des comptes
publics monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bazin vous abordez des sujets
que nous avons longuement évoqué ici
même lors du débat d'orientation des
finances publiques il y a quelques jours
au cours d'une soirée avec le rapporteur
général Husson le président rénal est
beaucoup d'entre vous d'abord l'annonce
du président de la République sur la
baisse d'impôt pour les classements
moyennes je veux rappeler qu'elle
s'inscrit dans une politique résolue de
renforcement du pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui travaillent qui nous a
amenés à la suppression compensée de la
taxe d'habitation à la redevance télé
qui a été supprimée à la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu pour les deux
premières tranches à la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires et à
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu sur l'inflation cette politique
elle a un sens c'est redonné de
l'oxygène à tous ces Français qui se
lèvent le matin qui travaillent et qui
ont parfois le sentiment qu'il finance
avec leurs impôts un modèle qui permet à
certains de ne pas travailler ou des
services publics qui se dégradent ce qui
nécessite pour nous évidemment de leur
redonner du pouvoir d'achat et d'agir
sur
douter d'une croissance à 2,5% en 2022
nous l'avons dépassé et qu'à l'automne
dernier certains remettaient en cause le
fait que nous aurions une croissance
positive en 2023 et que les
prévisionnistes sont en train
progressivement de s'aligner sur notre
prévision à 1% de croissance pour cette
année 2023 le FMI que vous avez évoqué
est à 0,8 l'eau CDE est à 0,7 et donc
oui nous avons une économie qui résiste
parce que nous avons des entreprises qui
embauchent et qui investissent c'est bon
pour le pays c'est bon pour l'emploi et
c'est même bon pour les finances
publiques je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le président de la
République lui-même a précisé que cette
baisse d'impôt sur le classement moyenne
serait effective quand la trajectoire
des finances publiques le permettra à
travers les documents budgétaires que
vous avez rappelé par être raisonnable
disons moins des raisonnables
d'envisager cette baisse à l'échéance du
présent du précédent quinquennat en
conséquence les Français auront bien
compris que la situation des classes
moyennes s'améliorera quand Emmanuel
Macron ne sera plus président de la
République
la parole est à notre collègue Marie
Arlette carlti pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
[Applaudissements]
l'école insalubre que le maire de
Marseille a la volonté de réhabiliter
déjà ils avaient le sentiment que la
République les avait abandonnés mais
désormais ils savent que chaque jour il
risque leur vie car il ne faut pas se
trouver au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment la police pylone les points de
Deal fait des records de prise de cheat
c'est bien mais à l'évidence ça ne
marche pas vous avez déployé des moyens
importants notamment sur Marseille ça ne
suffit pas c'est donc sur votre doctrine
que je vous interroge est-ce que vous
croyez par exemple que c'était vraiment
le moment d'affaiblir la police
judiciaire alors que leur objectif c'est
justement de démanteler les réseaux oui
la guerre des gangs nous l'avons entendu
sur ce répartit partout dans le pays et
nous aurions temps de penser que cette
situation n'est propre qu'à Marseille
nous ici nous soutenons les forces de
l'ordre nous respectons la police mais
quand les choses ne fonctionnent pas
c'est au ministre à revoir sa copie
alors aujourd'hui madame la ministre
au-delà de Marseille c'est pour toutes
les villes de France que nous nous
indignions et que nous vous demandons ce
que vous comptez faire
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre en charge des collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice Carlotti
oui nous partageons ce constat
inacceptable en fait depuis le début de
l'année ce sont 17 personnes qui ont été
tuées dans le cadre domicile liées au
trafic de stupéfiants et je voudrais ici
au nom de Gérald Darmanin de madame la
Première ministre et de tout le
gouvernement avoir un mot pour leur
famille et leurs proches endeuillés mais
face à cette situation intolérable là où
nous divergeons c'est que le ministère
de l'intérieur des Outre-mer est
pleinement mobilisé d'ores et déjà c'est
pas ce que nous quand on fait c'est ce
que nous faisons et si vous me le
permettez je vais le rappeler entre 2021
2022 c'est 300 policiers qui ont été
dépêchés en renfort et contrairement à
ce que vous disiez en début d'année
c'est dix nouveaux policiers qui sont
venus renforcer la police judiciaire et
qui permettent de créer un groupe
supplémentaire pour l'office anti
stupéfiant ces trois compagnies de CRS
qui ont également été affectés en
permanence à Marseille soit un total de
plus 240 policiers ces 30 jeunes
policiers sortis d'école qui ont été
affectés à Marseille depuis le 2 mai
madame la sénatrice 11 nouveaux
policiers arriveront à la police
judiciaire d'ici septembre pour
renforcer la brigade de recherche et
d'intervention 90 postes qui ont été
ouverts rien que sur Marseille dans le
cas du prochain mouvement de mutation et
qui arriveront en septembre prochain
enfin grâce à la loop me que vous avez
voté en ce début d'année une nouvelle
compagnie de type CRS numéro 8 sera
implanté à Marseille et même d'ici la
fin de l'année 2023 cette politique
montre des effets concrets d'ores et
déjà madame la sénatrice bien sûr
insuffisant mais il me faut les rappeler
de gens via mars 2023 ce sont 362
opérations visant des points de deal qui
ont été effectués à Marseille
aboutissant la saisie de 500 kg de
drogue 40 armes 800000
incroyable d'avoir criminel des armes
800 000 armes d'avoir criminels donc oui
madame il nous faut poursuivre et vous
avez raison de nous interroger mais
entendez les réponses que nous apportons
d'ores et déjà je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue Max
Brisson pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale après
un long silence votre enseigne était
particulièrement attendu on vous annonce
loin de répondre aux besoins de réforme
de l'école
futur plus polémique que saluer elles
ont cependant offert de nouveaux débats
sur la laïcité et la mixité sociale j'ai
donc trois questions à vous poser à
l'aune de la composition du nouveau
Conseil des Sages de laïcité
entendez-vous redéfinir ce principe
fondamental d'autres République qui
prévoient jusqu'à présent à l'école
publique alors que le chef de l'État
vous invite à ne pas réveiller de vieux
conflits pourrez-vous présenter un jour
votre plan sur la mixité sociale à
l'école finalement monsieur le ministre
avez-vous la confiance du président de
la République pour réformer et diriger
l'éducation nationale
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur papendaye
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Brisson
trois questions plutôt ou plutôt deux
auquel je vais répondre successivement
la première porte sur les questions de
laïcité j'ai eu l'occasion déjà de
m'exprimer devant vous pour
indiquer que d'une part la laïcité doit
être observée de manière ferme et
stricte nous devons respecter
strictement la loi de 2004 qui est notre
boussole en la matière être ferme à
l'égard de celles et ceux qui
contreviennent au principe de laïcité et
depuis l'automne il y a eu des conseils
de discipline il y a eu des sanctions
qui ont été prononcées mais j'ai
également eu l'occasion de dire que la
laïcité c'est aussi une pédagogie la
laïcité ne doit pas seulement être
contrainte elle doit être aimée c'est ce
que disait les républicains à la fin du
19e siècle la République ne doit pas
être crainte seulement elle doit être
aimée nous devons donc développer une
pédagogie de la laïcité c'est très
important pour convaincre et ne pas
simplement faire respecter au sens
strict du terme nous avons pour cela un
conseil des sages qui oriente l'action
du ministre fournit des éléments
intellectuels des éléments de doctrine
et nous avons aussi en parallèle une
administration avec plus de 600
personnes dans les équipes valeurs de la
République qui travaillent à faire
respecter la laïcité sur le terrain de
façon ferme avec discernement mais de
manière très ferme en ce qui concerne
votre deuxième question je vais dévoiler
ce soir puisque nous allons signer un
accord avec le secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique pour ce qui
concerne le privé et une batterie de
mesure en ce qui concerne le public de
nature à favoriser la mixité car la
mixité c'est bon pour le climat scolaire
c'est bon pour le climat social c'est
bon pour les niveaux des élèves c'est
bon aussi pour la laïcité monsieur
Brisson
monsieur le ministre acteur le président
de République face caméra
multiplie depuis un an les annonces sur
l'organisation scolaire et son évolution
acte 2 seuls et en militant pour enfin
exister vous concentrez sur deux sujets
une laïcité à géométrie variable qui
conduit au torpillage du conseil des
sages et qui laisse sans directives
proviseur et professeur puis en simulage
éculé de l'enseignement privé qui serait
vieux fantasme de gauche la source des
défaillances de l'enseignement public
acte 3 le président République vous
rappelle à l'ordre et vos plans sont
rangés au placard le problème est qu'à
force de tirer a eu et Adia la rue de
Grenelle et l'Élysée passent à côté de
l'essentiel la réforme d'un service
public à bout de souffle cessez donc de
jouer avec l'Elysée ce bien mauvais
votre ville monsieur le ministre au-delà
de vos idées personnelles écrivantes la
France a besoin de nos élans réformateur
pour son école merci
la parole est notre collègue Elisabeth
Doisneau pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question concerne les mineurs non
accompagnés une question qui n'est pas
nouvelle et qui demande une réponse en
fait interministérielle parce qu'elle
peut aussi bien avoir une réponse sur le
plan du ministère de l'Intérieur pour
les flux migratoires que sur la justice
avec l'évaluation de la minorité que sur
la solidarité que sur la protection de
l'enfance que sur l'éducation même le
travail quand nous avons des chefs
d'entreprise qui demandent à ce que on
puisse maintenir déjà sur notre
territoire pour assurer soit des
apprentissages ou du travail dans nos
entreprises artisanales donc c'est
vraiment un ensemble de réponses qui est
attendu et aujourd'hui le cri d'alarme
est lancé par le président de
l'Association des départements de France
François Sauvadet qui dit que la
situation est alarmante et il a raison
la situation est alarmante 5000 mineurs
non accompagnés qui sont arrivés depuis
le début de l'année et notamment 2000
dans les Alpes-Maritimes et je voudrais
rappeler le chiffre entre 2021 et 2022
c'était 900 mineurs non accompagnés en
plus dans le seul département des
Alpes-Maritimes et la situation est
vraiment catastrophique nous devons agir
et je voudrais vous poser tout
simplement cette question va-t-on parler
dans la loi immigration de cette
question des mineurs non accompagné il
n'y a rien à ce jour dans cette loi
concernant les jeunes alors que nous
devons et les accompagner avec humanité
mais aussi avec responsabilité et faire
en sorte que les choses soient
acceptables aussi pour l'ensemble de la
population nous devons aussi
penser à ce que nous avons voté dans la
loi taquet c'est à dire du 7 février
2022 nous avions trois articles qui
étaient concernés par les mineurs non
accompagnés aujourd'hui rien n'est
possible puisque ce ne ce n'est pas
passé au Conseil d'État la troisième
question c'est comment comptez-vous
faire pour aider financièrement les
conseils départementaux qui sont à bout
de souffle aujourd'hui et les moyens
financiers ont diminué ces dernières
années je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole que la
ministre délégué
en charge des collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Doisneau avec le ministre de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer Gérard
Darmanin nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés sur cette question et vous le
savez des mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés qui est à la fois complexe
mais crucial pour nos territoires et nos
départements
et pour eux bien sûr madame
c'est une question particulièrement
actuelle puisque en 2022 quelques
chiffres ils étaient 14 782 en 2021 ils
sont 11 315 ils étaient 11315 et les
remontées des départements qui ont la
charge comme vous l'avez indiqué de
l'accueil de ces jeunes montre une
augmentation prévisible de ces chiffres
cette préoccupation nous la partageons
c'est pour cela que la mission nationale
des mineurs non accompagnés de la
Direction de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse au ministère de la jeunesse
et pleinement mobilisé et à l'écoute des
remontées des départements c'est encore
pour cela que je suis personnellement en
contact régulier avec le président des
départements de France cher François
Sauvadet c'est pour cela évidemment qui
a été organisé à Vendôme la semaine
dernière une rencontre avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur la secrétaire d'État
l'enfance et qu'ils ont reçu ensemble
les élus les représentants du
département des Alpes-Maritimes tout
particulièrement exposé dans ce contexte
nous allons ainsi apporter des réponses
concrètes à la situation de tension que
vous avez décritée que nous partageons
et que connaît ce département en
particulier mais comme vous l'avez dit
que connaissent aussi d'autres
départements soutien aux équipes
départementales en charge de
l'évaluation recherche de la mise en
oeuvre des solidarités inter
départementales suspension de la clé de
répartition concours exceptionnel de
l'État toutes ces pistes sont à l'étude
actuellement pour améliorer encore notre
dispositif en lien avec les
collectivités tout particulièrement avec
l'Association des départements de France
le soutien de l'État au département dans
cette mission très sensible et totale
offrir un séminaires la prise en charge
nécessaire est indispensable comme vous
l'avez indiqué comme nous devons
préserver tout comme nous devons
préserver les équilibres de notre
République et des territoires également
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre
collègue philippe Dominati pour les
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur président madame la
ministre il y a quelques jours un
quotidien a publié son enquête annuelle
concernant l'inquiétude des Français
vis-à-vis de leur liberté individuelle
64% d'entre eux considèrent que les
atteintes à la liberté individuelle se
sont aggravés au cours de la dernière
décennie
ce chiffre est également réparti entre
les électeurs de gauche plus de 70%, les
entreprises 78% et évidemment les autres
catégories de France
les interdictions peuvent elles sont
quotidiennes les collectivités
territoriales y participent
je n'ai pas le temps évidemment les
énumérer mais ça va de la possibilité de
se laver d'arroser de chasser de choisir
son médecin sa santé se faire vacciner
ou pas se faire vacciner de choisir sa
fin de vie
pour autant les Français sont les
citoyens les plus prodigués vis-à-vis de
du pays il paye la dette il paye les
impôts les plus élevés des démocraties
ils payent le plus grand nombre d'agents
publics et l'État mord la main de ceux
qui les nourrissent je suis un
républicain
je ne suis pas fan des monarchie parce
que je suis toujours étonné de voir que
des contribuables peuvent payer ou
enrichir le patrimoine de leur prince
mais force est de constater que entre le
millier d'anglais qui est au sacre de
Charles III
et la pauvreté la solitude de notre
président de la République sur les
Champs-Élysées entouré de dix policiers
pour un spectateur je m'interroge ma
question est de savoir
madame le Premier ministre madame les
ministres quelles instructions vous
donner à votre administration pour avoir
les précautions de ne plus enquiquiner
les Français au nom des précautions
élémentaires au nom de la trilogie de
votre gouvernement
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vous interrogez
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer Gérald Darmanin sur un récent
monsieur le sénateur Dominati sur un
récent sondage de l'Ifop
personne bien entendu ne concerne de
quand est le sérieux de l'institut Ifop
mais nous ne perdons pas de vue qu'on
parle ici d'une perception
subjective d'un sentiment si on s'en
tient la réalité des faits et du droit
nous souhaitons insister sur le fait que
nous sommes dans un état de droit et que
l'action du gouvernement
tout comme celui des forces de l'ordre
et guidé par nos principes
constitutionnels et nos règles
juridiques que nous partageons tous la
liberté d'expression et en son sein la
liberté de manifestation sont des
principes constitutionnels auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés mais nous rappelons
également que des restrictions
libertaires individuelles sont possibles
dans notre État de droit sous conditions
bien évidemment ainsi les restrictions à
la liberté de manifester doivent être
strictement proportionnées au motifs
d'intérêt général à défendre
les restrictions à liberté de manifester
doivent aussi être motivés par un risque
avéré de troubles à l'ordre public alors
vous le savez peut-être monsieur mais ça
me semblait opportun de le rappeler je
rappelle également que dans notre pays
toute restriction liberté individuelle
est soumise au strict contrôle d'un juge
des arrêtés préfectoraux d'interdiction
de manifestations ont déjà été confirmés
par le juge mais faut-il rappeler que
d'autres arrêtés préfectoraux
d'interdictions de manifestations ont
aussi été annulés par la justice alors
quelques exemples un colloque de
l'Action française autorisé par le
tribunal administratif samedi 13 mai
alors que le préfet de police avait pris
un arrêté d'interdiction une
manifestation organisée par la même
action française dimanche 14 mai qui a
défilé en hommage agenda la
démonstration est ainsi faite que nos
institutions fonctionnent et que l'État
de droit est respecté je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
mérité alors en 40 ans un quart des
oiseaux c'est à dire 800 millions
d'oiseaux ont disparu en Europe
non non
ne vous laissez pas aller c'est
plaisanteries faciles
et cet effondrement est directement
imputable aux pesticides et à
l'agriculture intensive chaque année 300
000 personnes dont 12 000 enfants
meurent prématurément de la pollution de
l'air en Europe le niveau des nappes
phréatiques et dramatique et l'Europe du
Sud brûle déjà alors que nous sommes
loin de l'été encore
et voilà que le Président de la
République
annonce vouloir une pause dans la
réglementation environnementale
européenne c'est consternant et c'est
d'autant plus concernant que deux
directives majeures sont actuellement en
discussion la directive concernant les
pesticides et la directive concernant
les produits chimiques et est aussi en
discussion le Green Deal avec la
question du principe du pollueur-payeur
et avec ces déclarations est-ce que le
Président de la République ne
rapprocherait pas en fait la France du
côté obscur de la force c'est à dire de
ces pays qui font le choix de céder Audi
Olivier économique et qui font le choix
de du cynisme de l'efficacité économique
immédiate au détriment de la santé des
Européens
la France risque avec cette déclaration
si c'était si elle était confirmée de
torpiller les efforts que l'Europe doit
faire pour accélérer sa transition
écologique alors nous sommes dans une
course de vitesse aujourd'hui contre la
destruction du vivant nous sommes dans
des difficiles négociations dans l'Union
européenne dans quel camp est la France
qui faut-il croire est-ce qu'il faut
croire le ministre Béchu qui au 1er
janvier nous souhaitait à tous une année
d'accélération de la transition
écologique ou est-ce qu'il faut croire
le ministre Lescure qui demande 50 poses
de la transition écologique
pour vous répondre la parole l'État au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice rossignol
d'abord merci d'avoir fait écho
cette étude hier qui pointe cette
disparition inquiétante de la mortalité
des
oiseaux à l'échelle européenne et les
causes qui sont avérées nous sommes à
quelques jours
d'une séquence très importante à
l'Unesco de la négociation d'un traité
sur la fin de la pollution plastique qui
va se tenir en France parce que le
Président de la République a souhaité je
suis heureux que vous m'interrogiez sur
ses propos qui ne doivent pas être mal
compris
d'abord dans quel cas ça se passe dans
le cadre d'une conférence de presse
choisie par le Président de la
République à l'Élysée pour expliquer
qu'il faut accélérer sur la
réindustrialisation écologique du pays
et ça commence par une diapo projetée
qui est celle du GIEC pour expliquer ce
qui se passe et pour dire que nous
devons changer de braquet parce que
pendant trop d'années on a baissé nos
émissions en désudre industrialisant et
que l'écologie ceux qui en parle le plus
sont pas nécessairement ceux qui ont
fait le plus sous le quinquennat que
vous avez ardemment soutenu la baisse
des émissions était de 1% par an elle a
été doublée pendant le dernier
quinquennat et l'ambition de la doubler
à nouveau ce qui a été annoncé ce
jour-là c'est que nous allons nous
saisir d'un texte européen négocié par
le Président de la République le net 0
pour faire en sorte de pouvoir attribuer
des subventions au projet qui
correspondent à une excellence
écologique environnementale dans un
cadre qui est celui de la planification
écologique souhaitée par le Haut Conseil
pour le climat confié à la première
ministre de manière à assurer la
transversalité
le sujet c'est vu le nombre de textes
qui viennent d'être voté et ceux qui
sont encore devant nous riches et sur
dans quelle mesure nous faisons en sorte
maintenant de mettre les financements
c'est la phrase du président de la
République pour appliquer les
dispositions qui ont été prises plutôt
que d'ajouter des textes à des textes
alors que nous en avons déjà beaucoup
devant nous un exemple euro 7 on a il y
a quelques mois dit ensemble qu'il
fallait qu'on aille vers la
planification de la transition
écologique des voitures avec
l'électrification dans le même temps
l'évolution de la norme ne doit pas
concerner le moteur c'est la pause mais
se concentrer sur les autres éléments il
n'y a pas de contradiction entre le fait
d'expliquer qu'on doit intensifier notre
action sur la base des textes existants
qui sont déjà nombreux tout en
continuant en négocier de nouveau mais
en ajoutant pas chaque jour un texte qui
vient remplacer le précédent l'ambition
est totale la pose n'est pas pour
l'ambition
la parole de notre collègue Françoise
Dumont pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adressait à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la ministre en juin 2022 la
Commission européenne a publié une
proposition de règlement intitulée loi
sur la restauration de la nature il
s'agit de l'une des mises en application
de la stratégie européenne du pacte vert
dans ce contexte la commission
Environnement du Parlement européen qui
examine au fond le projet de règlement
doit entériner sa position le 15 juin
prochain dans son article 10 la loi
prévoit que les États membres de romps
devront écouter bien augmenter la
quantité de bois mort debout et au sol
la connectivité forestière les stocks de
carbone organiques dans les sols ainsi
que la part de forêt d'âge différent
avec une hausse de tous ces éléments qui
devraient être mesurées tous les trois
ans dans l'ensemble des États membres à
compter de 2030 cet article qu'on
revient complètement à la doctrine
française de lutte contre les incendies
de forêts que nous avons ici au Sénat
renforcés et sécurisé avec l'adoption de
la proposition de loi de nos collègues
jean-bassis Anne-Catherine Loisier
Pascal Martin et Olivier riadman visant
à renforcer l'approvision la prévention
pardon et la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie et qui prévoit entre
autres de gérer d'améliorer
l'aménagement et la valorisation des
forêts en appréhendant la défense contre
les incendies à l'échelle du massif de
financer la reconstitution de forêt plus
résiliente après l'incendie aussi madame
la ministre concernant ce texte européen
de restauration de la nature quelles
sont les actions françaises entreprises
pour faire reconnaître l'expertise et le
particularisme français en matière de
lutte contre les feux de forêt merci
pour vous répondre la parole de la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sédatrice Dumont en fait le 4
avril le Sénat adopté et vous l'avez dit
à l'unanimité j'étais au banc une
proport une proposition de loi
ambitieuse visant à renforcer les moyens
de prévention et de lutte contre les
incendies ce texte est aujourd'hui en
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et
essentiel pour notre avenir et nous
l'avons examiner tout lundi tout mardi
et actuellement je remercie Marc fhénot
qui est en train de poursuivre cet
examination qui cette examen pardon qui
s'opère de la façon la plus on va dire
constructive possible les incendies que
nous avons connues l'été dernier qui
frappent déjà des Pyrénées-Orientales à
l'heure où je vous parle nous rappelle
l'urgence d'agir face à ces phénomènes
amplifiés par le réchauffement
climatique et je profite de votre
question pour rappeler l'engagement de
nos sapeurs-pompiers
professionnelle ou volontaire et je
tiens à leur apporter à votre nom à tous
tout notre soutien concernant le sujet
spécifique du bois mort aucune règle
européenne ne s'oppose de manière
générale sur une parcelle forestière à
l'enlèvement de ce bois mort dans une
logique de prévention des incendies tout
particulièrement cet aspect revêt même
un enjeu important dans la prévention
des feux de forêt et dans la limitation
de leur propagation la réglementation
dite habitat appliquée par l'article
l401-1 du code de l'environnement
empêche pour sa part la destruction d'un
habitat d'une espèce protégée ce point
précis n'empêche pas l'enlèvement du
bois mort sur une parcelle alors en ce
sens la réglementation européenne
actuelle et la réglementation dite
habitat nous semble concilier le double
enjeu de préservation des habitats et de
la biodiversité d'une part mais aussi de
prévention et de lutte contre les
incendies je vous remercie je suis
ouverte à tous échange sur ce sujet je
vous recevrai Rai bien volontiers sur ce
sujet sur lequel on travaille déjà
depuis plusieurs mois ensemble merci
madame Dugon
oui madame la ministre j'entends votre
réponse qui se veut rassurante en
revanche moi je vous parlais de d'un
texte à l'étude actuellement en
commission Environnement du Parlement
européen et ma volonté est de vous
alerter justement contre un règlement
qui s'il s'applique aura des
conséquences très graves pour nos
massifs forestiers et bien sûr la
mission de nos soldats du feu merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est de notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la ville et
du Logement j'espère ne pas trop vous
contrarier madame la ministre qui vient
de s'exprimer précédemment elle concerne
le fameux DPE je n'aime pas les
acronymes mais il faut s'y faire des PE
diagnostic de performance énergétique
j'associe à ma question Jean-Michel
Arnaud sénateur des Hautes-Alpes très
investi sur cette question monsieur le
ministre je ne remets pas en cause la
bonne intention originelle du DPE mais
depuis Bernard de Clervaux nous savons
que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions peut-être allez-vous nous
convaincre mais nous voyons de nombreux
inconvénients à cette mise en place
précipitée du DPE je cite les délais
très contraints pour la réalisation des
travaux et donc le renchérissement des
coûts la question du de poids de mesure
entre les petites surfaces et les grands
logements
son caractère uniforme jacobin vertical
et descendant on a malheureusement
l'habitude qui n'indique pas les
variations qui ne tient pas en compte
qui n’intègre pas les variations
climatiques et c'est un homme du Nord
qui parle et enfin ces conséquences sur
l'offre de logement combien de logements
vont disparaître de l'offre de location
au moment même où ce profil une crise du
logement sans précédent monsieur le
ministre chers collègues pour conclure
vous l'avez compris pour nous le DPE
comporte des germes de fractures
sociales et territoriales et donc ma
question est la suivante comment
voyez-vous la mise en oeuvre du DPE sont
calendrier et ses conséquences sur la
crise du logement qui se profile je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
en charge du logement merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Olivier Hainaut oui le DPE est
utile le DPE a été réformé pour être
plus en phase avec la réalité de la
qualité des logements et il y a
effectivement une crise du logement mais
cette crise du logement ne doit pas nous
laisser entendre qu'on peut laisser
vivre nos concitoyens dans des passoires
thermiques le calendrier tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui il concerne d'abord
pour le 1er janvier 2025 les plus les
personnes thermiques les plus
importantes à partir des étiquettes g
puis 2028f etc les propriétaires
bailleurs comme les propriétaires
occupants sont accompagnés et
connaissent cette évolution depuis de
nombreuses années d'ailleurs les
propriétaires bailleurs continuent à
percevoir un loyer et pour ma part et je
crois que c'est notre position à tous on
ne peut pas des habitants vivre avec des
enfants dans des passoires thermiques
dans le fait qu'elle il fait très chaud
l'été très froid l'hiver dans lequel il
y a de la moisissure sur les fenêtres et
c'est le sens de cette mesure le
gouvernement agit à travers la mise en
place de France raynove à travers la
mise en place des cette année des
accompagnateurs Renov à travers ma prime
rénov qui se développe notamment Mappy
Renov sérénité qui doit accompagner les
plus fragiles à travers le doublement du
déficit foncier qui va permettre aux
propriétaires bailleurs d'être encore
mieux accompagné dans leur travaux et
donc toutes ces mesures mises bout à
bout doivent permettre de tenir ce
calendrier parce que ce calendrier il
est dans l'intérêt de ceux qui vivent
dans les passoires thermiques notamment
les plus fragiles de nos concitoyens
ensuite je n'ai pas un certain nombre de
particularités qui doivent être regardés
notamment dans les territoires de
montagne ou dans un certain nombre de
cas et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut
travailler à la rénovation thermique de
l'habitat collectif parce que bien
évidemment un propriétaire qui a son
appartement classé g dans un immeuble
dans lequel on n'aurait rien fait et
bien se retrouver en situation
d'impossibilité de faire et c'est
l'obligation qui nous est donnée c'est
de mieux accompagner l'habitat collectif
dans ces travaux de rénovation je vous
remercie
monsieur etno oui perplexe monsieur le
ministre nous sommes perplexe par
rapport à cette nouvelle forme de jeune
homme donc je suis et j'ai peur qu'il en
soit du DPE comme des portiques de la
taxe carbone du ZFE ou de main d'usane
enthousiasme initial perplexité lors de
la mise en œuvre et abandons en race
campagne à l'approche du mur de la
réalité je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 24 mai à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
en application de l'article 34-1 la
Constitution relative à la
reconnaissance du génocide ukrainien de
1932-1933 la séance est suspendue